the earth is inhabited by millions of
different life-forms from the tiniest
bacteria to the largest whales the
extraordinary diversity of life fills
every habitat scientists estimate that
there are well over 10 million species
living on the planet today but less than
2 million of these have been discovered
so far from the very beginning of life
all organisms have been connected
through common ancestors in a single
history of descent the great tree of
life
the tree of life is to me one of the
most amazing concepts that humans have
ever come up with the tree is a set of
genetic connections it's it's a
description of the relatedness of all
organisms this tree is over
three-and-a-half billion years old and
to think that all living creatures are
but leaves on the tips of this tree and
deeply interconnected through their
genes to me just an astounding concept
today scientists are embarked on a great
new age of discovery charting all of the
branches of the tree of life
this was a real species that existed to
discover the shape of the Tree of Life
teams of scientists around the globe are
gathering data in the field and in the
laboratory to reconstruct the
genealogical relationships that link all
life-forms past and present utilizing
new methods and cutting-edge
technologies scientists are meeting the
enormous challenge of discovering the
millions of branches that make up the
tree of life many groups of organisms
have a very complex ancestry and we're
trying to record events that happened
very fast
a long time ago and that's very very
challenging in his book the Origin of
Species published in 1859 biologists
Charles Darwin compared life on the
planet to a great tree Darwin realized
that the process of evolution implied
shared ancestry going all the way back
to the beginning of life ever since
Darwin scientists have attempted to
reconstruct the historical relationships
among species today evolutionary
biologists refer to the tree of life as
a phylogeny phylogeny is a history it's
a history of branching within a lineage
within a group of species
how does this branching occur imagine a
population of bunnies continually
reproducing giving rise to one
generation after another at some point a
river changes its course creating two
separate bunny populations and
preventing them from reproducing with
one another later in one of these
populations a baby pops up with a
mutation a new feature represented here
by the color purple it turns out that
purple bunnies are increasingly
successful in this environment and soon
the entire population on that side of
the river is made up of purple bunnies
sometime later imagine that this
population of purple bunnies is split in
two again in this case by the appearance
of a volcano in one of the now separated
populations a new mutation results in a
red colored bunny red colored bunnies do
well in that environment and eventually
all bunnies on that side of the volcano
are colored red this process of
successive splitting generates a
branching pattern a tree along which we
can trace the evolution of new
characteristics in this case from tan to
purple and later from purple to red the
search for the underlying branching
pattern of the Tree of Life typically
begins with the study of the visible
characteristics of organisms
to aid in their research evolutionary
biologists increasingly also make use of
a whole new data set genetic material
itself sequences of DNA molecules found
inside of each cell by comparing the DNA
sequences of different species
evolutionary biologists are able to
reconstruct the Tree of Life with
increasing confidence while these new
data have shed light on the tree the
increasing size of phylogenetic datasets
has also highlighted just how difficult
this problem is so the problem for the
tree of life is that it's really immense
there are known to be something like 1.8
million species on earth alive today but
all of us think that the number is
actually much larger than that when we
get around to discovering it all will be
more like 10 million or more than 10
million species so when we're trying to
reconstruct any portion of the Tree of
Life it's a process of elimination
we examine all the possible hypotheses
of how these species could be related to
one another to do that rigorously you'd
have to look at all the possible trees
all the possible ways these species
could be related to one another for
three species they're just three trees
for four species there's 15 possible
arrangements for five species there's
105 but by the time I get to ten species
it's getting up to 34 million 34 million
is still doable but when you get to 50
species it's an immense number there are
so many possible solutions that we can't
possibly examine all of them
individually so even for just a tree of
50 species there are more possible ways
of building a tree than there are atoms
in the entire universe sample the
solution what's needed are shorter so
that biologists don't have to examine
every single possible tree computer
scientists are actively exploring
methods to reconstruct phylogenetic
relationships and have successfully
developed a variety of new highly
efficient approaches to the problem it
took 10 years of developing techniques
and experimenting with them and trying
new techniques and just continuing with
lots of real datasets and simulated
datasets and then coming across the
ideas that actually led us to come up
with these breakthroughs the development
of new theory and mathematical methods
the availability of massive amounts of
DNA data and ever more powerful
computers have combined to fuel
unprecedented advances in our
understanding of the Tree of Life many
surprises have emerged from the
phylogenetic analysis of molecular
information one of the most unexpected
recent findings concerns an unusual
parasitic flowering plant called
rafflesia they're found in Southeast
Asia and they produce the world's
largest flowers the biggest of them is
like three feet in diameter weighs more
than 20 pounds and looks and smells like
rotting flesh early on and people
thought wow this is not even a flowering
plant it's a it's a fungus but very
quickly they realize that no indeed it's
a flowering plant and what we're now
increasingly finding out is that groups
of organisms like the rafflesia AC e
with in the past tended to kind of
cluster them together we're now finding
out that they represent many independent
branches in in the Tree of Life
their closest relatives are not things
with large flowers but instead they're
actually things with really tiny
millimeter sized flowers knowledge of
the Tree of Life is changing the way we
look at the diversity of life on earth I
think what's great about the Tree of
Life is that it is reorienting the way
we think about almost everything in
biology we will have gone from
essentially no knowledge of the Tree of
Life are just very vague knowledge to a
very complete knowledge of all the major
branches and how they're related to one
another our understanding of the
evolution of the Earth's biodiversity
and the relationships of all life-forms
to one another is increasing rapidly
through this monumental scientific
undertaking the study of the Tree of
Life is also yielding insights of
enormous practical importance including
life-saving applications ultimately the
Tree of Life provides a much deeper
comprehension of each and every
organisms place on earth including our
own